the Carter Paige FISA application has
been released in part big portions of it
though were redacted and those portions
could help reveal the extent to which
the Obama administration surveilled the
Trump campaign which they did
congressman Devin Nunez is the chairman
of the House Intelligence Committee he
represents California in the house
representatives he joins us tonight mr.
chairman thank you for coming on so
you've seen the entire document the
entire application FISA applications to
spy on Carter page and then the Trump
campaign much of it was redacted pages
and pages redacted do you believe
knowing what was redacted that the
public has a right to see that
information absolutely so what we heard
for a long time is that the memo that we
created to make sure that the American
public knew that the FISA contained the
still dossier or the so-called dirt that
the Clinton campaign paid for got bought
it from Russians the fed it to the FBI
in order to get a FISA warrant on Carter
page we said that that made up the bulk
of the FISA we were we were made fun of
we were told that was wrong that we were
lying when in fact we were 100% right it
did make up the bulk of the FISA then
you saw you notice that right after that
came out they said well but what's
really important is the information
that's redacted then lo and behold they
found out that just a couple months
before the Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee had actually
asked for about 20 pages at least 20
pages to be Declassified of the Carter
page FISA those today Tucker remain
redacted and hidden from the public we
believe that if the public saw that
information they would have a very clear
picture to what director Comey called a
mosaic and I think the public under
needs to understand what is this mosaic
that was created by the FBI fed to the
DOJ fed to a FISA Court in order to spy
on an American citizen and effectively
get information directly from the Trump
campaign yes you hear you have the Obama
administration spying on a rival
political campaign specifically on a man
who has never been charged for the
crimes that were the pretext of the
spying in the first place and yet no one
on the Left cares at all and I guess my
question to you again having seen the
information that I'm not allowed to see
is there a good reason the national
security based reason to keep that
information from the public on what
grounds was it redacted oh quite the
opposite there is a national security
reason to make sure that the American
public sees this in its entirety because
this is a phony FISA okay the Department
of Justice and the FBI put something
together that is completely fraudulent
in order to spy an American citizen it's
our job as Congress to bring sunlight
and full transparency to this okay okay
okay FBI to let that happen okay then
why don't you send it to me now and I
will put it on the air in the back half
for the show I mean it I'm dead serious
you are the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee it is you're
elected by voters to make these
judgments bureaucrats elected by nobody
are telling us threatening us basically
this hurts national security you're the
one with the power why don't you send it
to me we will put it on the air and let
the public well done is there a penalty
for that well just remember I yeah I'm
not the one with the power now
hypothetically could I go to the House
floor or could I go out in my official
duties and tell the American public
what's in the rest of that FISA I could
however I mean you already see remember
most of the media and the left is
against us and against it they don't
want the rest of this out they want to
keep this hidden can you imagine the
field day they would have against me or
other but if any other Republicans
talked about waivers and classified
information so you have journalists
sunbathing back to the battery holding
information back I mean that since it if
you live in a world where journalists
are saying the public should know less
they have been discredited by definition
we don't have to listen to them they are
not journalists there's something less
there flacks so is there a penalty for
doing that you understand really
importantly do you understand chucker
yes yes that's that that's the problem
you understand this there's a penalty
right so so we can't create a situation
but what can happen right now how do we
get this done is the president just
needs to step in and declassify this
said he doesn't want to get involved but
quite frankly that he needs to get
involved in this it doesn't involve him
if he would just declassify it then we
as Congress would have no problem coming
on your show and talking about this
Declassified information yeah because
there's no argument against understand
but you can't believe it's courtesy yeah
well it you know I hope someone will
leak it to me I do I do because I think
the public has a right to know and I'd
love to know why the public doesn't have
a right to know and I'd love with all
these anchors every day telling me I
don't have a right so really why speak
slowly so I can understand it's
infuriating mr. chairman thank you for
all the work you have done it is and I
hope someone will send that to me we'll
put it right under your tongue
immediately